we've talked a lot about demand so now
let's talk about supply and we'll use
grapes as this example will pretend to
be grape farmers of some sort so I will
start by introducing you and may be able
to in purple in honor of the grapes to
the law of supply which like the law of
demand makes a lot of intuitive sense if
we hold all else equal in the next few
videos we'll talk about what happens
when we change some of those things that
we're going to hold equal right now but
if you hold all else equal and the only
thing that you're doing is you're
changing price then the law of supply
says that if the price goes up I'll just
say P for price if the price goes up
then the supply let me be careful the
quantity supplied the quantity supplied
supplied goes up and then you can
imagine if the price goes down the
quantity the quantity supplied goes down
and you might already notice that I was
careful to say quantity supplied
quantity supplied and it's just like we
saw with demand when we talk about
demand going up or down we're talking
about the entire price quantity
relationship shifting when we talk about
a particular quantity demanded we say
quantity demanded we don't just say
demand and this is the exact same thing
for supply we're talking about a
particular quantity will be careful to
say quantity if we talk about supply
increasing we're talking about the
entire relationship shifting or either
up or down so let's just make sure that
this makes intuitive sense for us and I
think it probably does let's think about
ourselves as grape farmers and I'll make
a little supply schedule right over here
supply so grape grape supply schedule
which is really just a table showing the
relationship between all else equal the
price and the quantity supplied so let's
label some scenarios over here just like
we did with the demand schedule
scenarios scenarios and then let's put
our price over here it's going to be in
price this will be in in price per pound
per the per pound price of grapes and
then this is the quantity produced over
time period and whenever we do any of
these supply or demand schedules we're
talking over a particular time period it
could be per day it could be per month
it could be per year but that's the only
way to make some sense of okay how much
what is the quantity per day going to be
produced if that's the price so if we
didn't say per day
we don't know what we're really talking
about quantity quantity supplied
quantity supplied and so let's just say
scenario a scenario a if the price per
pound of grapes is 50 cents if it's 50
cents per pound actually let me just do
let me just do let me just do round
numbers but you get the idea if the
price per pound is one dollar let's just
say for us we consider that to be a
relatively low price and so weõll only
will only kind of do the easiest land
are our most fertile land where it's
easy to produce grapes and maybe the
fertile and cheap land so no one else
wants to use that land for other things
it's only good for growing grapes and so
we will we will provide so this is price
per pound so per pound and in that
situation we can produce one thousand
pounds in this year and I've never been
a grape farmer so I actually don't know
if that's a reasonable amount or not but
I'll just go with a thousand pounds now
let's take scenario B let's say the
price goes up to $2 well now not only
would we produce what we were producing
before but we might now want to maybe
buy some more land land that might have
had other uses Nate land that's maybe
not as productive for grapes but we
would because now we can get more for
grapes and so maybe now we are willing
to maybe now we're willing to produce
two thousand pounds to two thousand two
thousand pounds and we could keep going
the same same dynamics keep happening so
let's say the price if the price were
three dollars three dollars per pound
now we do want to produce more we'll
what maybe we're even willing to work a
little harder or plant things closer to
each other or maybe I or maybe I'll get
even more land involved that
otherwise used for other crops and so
then I get and then I'm going to produce
2,500 pounds and I'll do one more one
more scenario let's say scenario D the
price goes to $4 a pound same dynamic I
will stop planting other crops use them
now for grapes because great prices are
so high and so I will produce I will
produce two thousand seven hundred and
fifty pounds and so we can draw a supply
curve just like we were had drawn demand
curves so just like and it's the same
exact convention which I'm not a fan of
putting price on the vertical axis
because as you see we tend to talk about
price as the independent variable we
don't always talk about it that way and
in most of math and science you put the
independent variable on the horizontal
axis but the convention and economics is
to put it on the vertical axis so price
on the vertical axis so then this is
really price per pound per per pound and
then in the horizontal axis quantity
produce or thousand quantity let me just
write quantity produced I'll say in the
next year we're assuming all of this is
for the next year so next year next year
and it's in thousands of pounds so I'll
put it in thousands thousands of pounds
and so let's see we go all the way from
1000 to close to 3,000 so to say this is
one thousand that's one for one thousand
this two thousand and that is three
thousand and then the price goes all the
way up to four so it's one two three and
then four so we can just plot these
points these are specific points on the
supply curve so it would $1.00 we would
supply a thousand points a thousand
pounds at $1 thousand pounds that
scenario a at two dollars two dollars we
would supply two thousand pounds to
dollars we'd supply two thousand pounds
that's scenario B at three dollars we'd
supply supply 25 hundred pounds three
dollars oh sorry I want to make up see
notice I get my axis confused this is
price
is what we're kind of when we talk about
it this way that we're kind of viewing
what the thing that's changing although
we don't always have to view it that way
so let's so at $1 thousand pounds $1
thousand pounds two dollars two thousand
pounds two dollars two thousand pounds
three dollars not this isn't three
dollars this is three dollars three
dollars 2500 pounds so right about there
that looks it's about 2500 but I want to
do it in that blue color so we don't get
confused so three dollars 2500 pounds
that's about right so this is scenario C
and then scenario D at four dollars
actually let me let me be a little bit
clearer with that because we're getting
kind of close so this is 2500 pounds
gets us right over here this is scenario
C and then scenario D at four dollars
four dollars 2750 so 2750 is like right
over there so that is four dollars that
is scenario D and if we connect them
they should all be on our supply on our
supply curve so they will all they will
all be it will look something like that
and there's some minimum price there's
some minimum price we would need to
supply some grapes at all we wouldn't
give them away for free so maybe that's
something that minimum price is like
over here that just even get started
producing grapes so this right over here
is what our supply curve would look like
now remember the only thing we're
varying here is the price so if the
price were to change all else equal we
would move along this curve here now in
the next few videos I'll talk about all
of those other things we've been holding
equal and what they would do at any
given price point to this curve or in
general what they would do to the curve